IN A FEW MINUTES PAMELA ANDERSON
JOINS US TONIGHT, AND TELLS US
ABOUT HER VISIT TO THE KREMLIN
RECENTLY.
BUT FIRST TONIGHT, YOU PROBABLY
HEARD THAT MELANIA TRUMP HAD A
KIDNEY OPERATION LAST MONTH,
THAT KIND OF THING HAPPENS TO
40-YEAR-OLDS, EVEN FAMOUS ONES.
SHE TOOK A FEW WEEKS TO RECOVER,
STAYED OFF TV AND DIDN'T GIVE
ANY SPEECHES, CULPRIT IS
DIFFICULT FOR SOMEONE WHO JUST
GOT OUT OF THE HOSPITAL.
BUT AT CNN, THEY ARE PROUD
JOURNALISTS AND IF THERE'S ONE
THING THEY KNEW FOR CERTAIN, ONE
THING THAT WAS DRUMMED INTO THEM
IS THAT REPUBLICAN FIRST LADIES
LIE A LOT AND ARE EVIL AND FOR
THE SAKE OF CIVILIZATION SHOULD
BE DESTROYED.
SO CNN DID NOT BUY A WORD OF
THAT AND THEY ASSIGNED THEIR
MOST DOGGED JOURNALIST TO CRACK
THE CASE, THE SQUEAK AND
PERSISTENT BRIAN STELTER.
HE UNDERSTOOD IMMEDIATELY THAT
THE WHOLE KIDNEY OPERATION STORY
WAS JUST A COVER FOR SOMETHING
DARKER AND MORE SINISTER, LIKELY
IN OTHER INTERNATIONAL SCANDAL
EMANATING FROM THAT DARK LORD
VLADIMIR PUTIN HIMSELF.
HE ENDED AS MUCH HIS VIEWERS.
>> ONE THING THE PRESIDENT OF
THE WHITE HOUSE HAVE BEEN QUIET
ABOUT IS MELANIA TRUMP AND HER
LAST TIME I CAUGHT A GLIMPSE OF
HER WAS ON MAY 10TH, 24 DAYS AND
MORE THAN THREE WEEKS.
THERE HAVE BEEN QUESTIONS ABOUT
HER SURGERY, HER TIME AT WALTER
REED AND NOW HER INVISIBILITY.
>> Tucker: QUESTIONS ABOUT HER
SURGERY, QUESTIONS ABOUT HER
TIME AT WALTER REED?
WHO IS ASKING THOSE QUESTIONS?
HE DIDN'T SAY BECAUSE HE
COULDN'T SAY.
THOSE ARE NOT REAL QUESTIONS AND
THIS IS NOT REPORTING, IF THE
PASSIVE-AGGRESSIVE ATTACK.
THE CNN POINT WAS THAT MELANIA
TRUMP IS A LIAR AND SHE'S DOING
SOMETHING IMMORAL.
SHE MUST BE, LOOK WHO SHE IS
MARRIED TO.
STEPHEN COLBERT CAME TO THE SAME
CONCLUSION, WATCH.
>> AS OF THE TIME WE ARE TAPING
THE SHOW, THE FIRST LADY HAS NOT
BEEN SEEN IN PUBLIC FOR 25 DAYS.
I'M NOT SURPRISED, I TOOK THAT
SHAWSHANK GUY YEARS TO TUMBLE
OUT.
MONIA IS SUPPOSEDLY REEMERGING
TO ATTEND AN EVENT AND IT WILL
BE CLOSE TO THE PRESS.
BUT THE WHITE HOUSE DID RELEASE
THE OFFICIAL PHOTO PROVING THE
FIRST LADY WAS TOTALLY THERE.
>> Tucker: OVER AT
ROLLING STONE WHICH APPARENTLY
STILL EXISTS SOMEONE CALLED
JAMIL SMITH SAID MELANIA TRUMP
WASN'T HIDING TO CONCEAL SIGNS
OF PHYSICAL ABUSE.
THEY THEN SUGGESTED THAT THE
PRESIDENT MAY HAVE PUNCHED MY
MONIA AND THEN ORDERED THE
SECRET SERVICE TO COVER IT UP.
KEEP IN MIND THAT AT ONE TIME HE
WAS A SERIOUS INTELLECTUAL, OR
WHAT PASSED FOR ONE IN
WASHINGTON.
AND NOW HE IS SIMPLY A BUFFOON.
AND WHEN THE ACTUAL MELANIA
TRUMP SHOWED UP AT A VETERANS
EVENT, VERY MUCH ALIVE AND
UNSCATHED, SO MUCH FOR ALL THOSE
QUESTIONS THAT BRIAN STELTER
PRETENDED TO CARE ABOUT.
WHAT'S INTERESTING ABOUT THIS IS
HOW MUCH JOURNALISTS PRETEND TO
HATE MELANIA TRUMP.
MELANIA TRUMP IS NOT AN
OVERBEARING PUBLIC FIGURE.
SHE'S NOT LECTURING YOU ABOUT
YOUR WEIGHT OR TRYING TO CONTROL
YOUR PERSONAL LIFE.
SHE DOESN'T WEIGH IN ON TAX
RATES OR GLOBAL WARMING.
IT'S LIKELY SHE WILL RUN FOR
SENATE IN NEW YORK WHEN THIS IS
OVER.
ONE THING SHE IS ONE OF HER
HUSBAND'S KEY POLITICAL
ADVISORS.
MANY OF YOU HAVE NOT EVEN HEARD
HER VOICE, SHE DOESN'T TALK MUCH
IN PUBLIC.
MELANIA TRUMP HAS DONE NOTHING
WRONG TO YOU, ANYONE YOU KNOW OR
ANYONE YOU WILL EVER MEET.
SHE MARRIED DONALD TRUMP, AND
THAT IS HER ONLY SIN IN THE EYES
OF THE PRESS CORPS AND IT'S
ENOUGH TO DISQUALIFY HER FROM
EVEN THE MOST BASIC
CONSIDERATION OF DECENCY.
HERE FOR EXAMPLE IS SUPER
SENSITIVE MODERN COMEDIAN GUY AT
JIMMY KIMMEL MAKING FUN OF HER
ACCENT WHICH HE THINKS IS SILLY
AND FUNNY SOUNDING, ALIEN,
REALLY.
>> I'M CURIOUS, JUST LIKE A CAT.
I ASK LOTS OF QUESTIONS ABOUT
THIS AND OF THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Tucker: DO YOU THINK KIMMEL
WOULD BE OKAY MOCKING THE ACCENT
OF HIS MANY GUATEMALAN
HOUSEKEEPERS?
WHAT ABOUT AN MS-13 MEMBER?
PLEASE COME UP THAT WOULD BE
RACIST.
BUT MELANIA TRUMP?
AT ONE TIME PEOPLE WOULD ARGUE
THAT PEOPLE SHOULD BE JUDGED FOR
WHAT THEY DO.
COLLECTIVE PUNISHMENT IS WRONG,
IT IS IMMORAL.
THAT'S WHAT THEY SAID.
DID THEY EVER REALLY BELIEVE
THAT?
WHO KNOWS, BUT THEY DON'T
BELIEVE IT NOW.
TAMMY, WHAT DO YOU MAKE -- JUST
TO BE TOTALLY CLEAR, I NEVER
TYPICALLY DEFENDED THE HONOR OF
POLITICIANS.
IN FACT, THERE IS A ROLE I
DON'T.
BUT MELANIA TRUMP IS NOT A
POLITICIAN, WHY ARE THEY
ATTACKING HER?
WHAT DOES SHE HAVE TO DO WITH
IT?
>> IN LARGE PART IT'S BECAUSE
THEY'RE JEALOUS AND ENVIOUS.
HERE, YOU HAVE A WOMAN WHO HAS
POWER, INFLUENCE, SHE'S
PERFECTLY LOVELY, SHE'S SMART
AND SPEAKS FIVE LANGUAGES.
YES, SHE MARRIED A MAN THAT THEY
DON'T LIKE BUT SHE HAS ACCESS TO
THINGS THAT THEY CAN NOW DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO.
THEY USED TO BE THE ONES THAT
WERE FAWNED OVER, WHO WOULD BE
LOOKED TO FOR POWER AND
APPOINTMENT AND CREDIBILITY.
NOW, AS A WOMAN WHO NEVER REALLY
CARES ABOUT THEM AND HAS GONE TO
CERTAINLY SOME COCKTAIL PARTIES
BUT DOESN'T CARE ABOUT WHAT THE
ELITES IN WASHINGTON NECESSARILY
THINGS.
SHE CARES ABOUT HER SON, HER
FAMILY, AND HER PARENTS AND THAT
IS HER CRIME AS WELL.
KEEP IN MIND, THIS IS FOR EVERY
WOMAN WHO HAS BEEN DARED TO BE
PART OF THIS ADMINISTRATION.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE
HYPOCRISY OF THE LEFT, IT IS THE
ATTACKS ON THESE WOMEN THAT ARE
MISOGYNISTIC.
WHEN THEY TALK ABOUT EITHER
BEING BEATEN BY THE PRESIDENT OR
HIDING IN WALTER REED, OR HAVING
TO SECRETE HERSELF AWAY, IT
PRESUMES THAT SHE IS A VICTIM,
THAT SHE IS HELPLESS, THAT SHE
IS NOT WILLING TO TAKE CARE OF
HER OWN LIFE.
THAT KIND OF MISOGYNY IS AN
INSULT NOT JUST TO THE
FIRST LADY BUT FOR WOMEN WHO DO
EXPERIENCE VIOLENCE AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
AND YET THESE ARE THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
CHAMPIONS FOR WOMEN.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS THAT
THE ARGUMENTS ABOUT THE
CHAMPIONS THAT COME FROM THE
CENTER RIGHT ARGUMENT, THAT
WOMEN ARE INDIVIDUALS, THAT THEY
ARE SMART IN THE FIRST LADY IS
AN EXAMPLE OF A POWERFUL WOMAN
LIVING A LIFE THAT BEST SUITS
HER, AND SHE SHOULD BE LAUDED
FOR THAT.
>> Tucker: SHE NEVER BOTHERED
ANYBODY.
I'M TRYING TO IMAGINE A
CONVERSATION WHERE JEFF ZUCKER
BECAUSE OF HIS ERRAND BOY AND
SAYS, IT'S TIME TO ATTACK HER.
AND I'M THINKING, IF YOU REALLY
THINK THAT IT IS APPEALING TO
ATTACK MELANIA TRUMP, AND, SHE
IS AT 57% FAVORABLE.
SHE HAD A MUCH HIGHER PERCENTAGE
OF MEN THAT WERE FAVORABLE TO
HER, BUT THAT MEANS YOU DON'T
WANT TO TALK MILLENIA BECAUSE
YOU ARE IN ATTACKING THE VOTERS
THAT YOU NEED.
THEY PROBABLY SEE THIS AS A
WRONG IDEA BECAUSE NO ONE USES
SILENCE BETTER THAN MELANIA
TRUMP.
THAT SILENCE THAT YOU SEE NOW
HAS ALL OF AMERICA WAITING TO
TUNE IN TOMORROW WHEN SHE
REAPPEARS ON THE SCENE.
SO POLITICALLY GIVEN HER
RATINGS, IT'S NOT A VERY SMART
THING FOR A COLUMNIST TO DO
THIS.
>> HE RAN THE POLITICAL
OPERATIONS AT THE WHITE HOUSE,
AND YOU USED DATA TO DO THAT.
WHEN PEOPLE BECOME SO EMOTIONAL
AND WHEN A POLITICAL CAUSE
BECOMES A MORAL CAUSE, IT'S
PRETTY HARD TO MAKE RATIONAL
DECISIONS, ISN'T IT?
>> I THINK THAT'S RIGHT.
A LOT OF WHAT WE SEE TODAY IS
GETTING BACK TO RATIONALITY IN
OUR POLITICS.
NOW HILLARY CLINTON AS
FIRST LADY ENDURED A LOT OF
ATTACKS WHEN SHE WENT INTO
HEALTH CARE AND CONTROVERSIAL
ISSUES.
BUT, IT TAKES A VILLAGE, THE
COUNTRY UNITED.
MELANIA TRUMP IS NOT IN
CONTROVERSIAL ISSUES, SHE'S
TRYING TO HELP KIDS.
SHE'S DOING THOSE THINGS THAT
THE COUNTRY CAN AGREED UPON.
>> THE WAY THAT THE LEFT HAS
FRAMED EVERYTHING IS A MORAL
DIVIDE.
NOTHING ABOUT TRUMP CAN BE GOOD
AND EVERYTHING THAT IS A
CONSTRUCT CAN BE GOOD.
AND, THAT'S FINE, LET'S DEAL
WITH POLICY ISSUES.
BUT REMEMBER THE ATTACKS ON THE
FIRST LADY I WOULD CONTEND
BECAUSE THE ATTACKS ON THE
PRESIDENT DON'T WORK.
I THINK THERE IS AN INHERENT
DECISION HERE TO DESTROY HIS
BASE OF SUPPORT AND THAT IS WHY
SHE HAS NOW BEEN TARGETED.
CLEARLY, SHE IS A STRONG WOMAN.
SHE KNOWS WHAT'S GOING ON HERE,
AND THE MEDIA TRIES TO
ENFRANCHISE HER BUT SHE WILL
STICK TO WHAT MATTERS TO HER.
CHILDREN'S LIVES, SUPPORTING HER
SON AND HER FAMILY.
SO THIS IS THE ARMY OF WHAT IT
IS OF COURSE, WHAT THE MEDIA IS
DOING AND WHAT SOME OF THE
ESTABLISHMENT IS DOING WHICH IS
CLAIMING
THAT WILL WORK AS A POLITICAL
MATTER.
>> I THINK THIS WILL BE OVER
TOMORROW, AND SHE'S GOTTEN MORE
ASTUTE ABOUT THE OFFICE OF THE
FIRST LADY.
DONALD TRUMP IS 40% FAVORABLE